It seems that there's
praise all round
in North Korea
after its latest
test of an intercontinental
ballistic missile.
State media reports leader Kim
Jong un personally guided the launch
of the one
song 18 Intercontinental
Ballistic Missile on Wednesday,
which flew for 74 minutes
before crashing down in the waters
near Japan.
The longest flight ever
carried out by this ICBM.
It was a solid fuel missile.
It's been called the north
most powerful nuclear weapon,
but it's unclear
if it could actually deliver
a nuclear payload.
A menacing milestone for North Korea's
missile program.
Pyongyang's latest ICBM launch
breaking its own record for the longest
ever missile flight.
A staggering 74 minutes hurtling
high above the earth at supersonic
speed, hitting
6000 kilometers
before splashing down in the sea.
The massive missiles
potential striking range,
the entire US mainland
and most of the world.
Pyongyang's most provocative
launch in months,
coinciding with this NATO's
summit in Lithuania,
quickly condemned by Japan
as an unacceptable threat
to regional stability.
South Korea's
military ready to overwhelmingly respond.
The ICBM,
a crown jewel in leader Kim Jong un's
nuclear arsenal,
protecting the power, fortune
and future of the ruling Kim family.
His young daughter,
Kim Jae, often
appearing alongside her dad,
barely ten years old.
The rising
star of a state propaganda campaign
carefully crafted by Kim's
younger sister,
the mastermind of the Kim family brand.
The leader's loyal confidant,
trusted adviser
and perhaps the most powerful woman
in North Korea.
She is the number two war,
that is for sure.
But actually,
she is very smart lady, and she after the
war, knows that her position is secure
only when her brother is secure.
Just five years ago,
very few people knew of Kim Yo Jong.
She stepped on the South Korean soil,
the first member of North
Korea's ruling family to cross the DMZ.
She carried a message of peace
from Pyongyang,
North Korean athletes and cheer squads.
Got a warm
welcome at the 2018 Winter Olympics.
She rose to fame as a fixture
at her brother's side.
Standing silently behind
Kim as he met with former
President Trump.
That brief period of diplomacy
feels like a distant memory.
The silent sister now
allowed voice of defiance,
issuing fiery statements on state media,
often laced with crude language.
This week,
she threatened to shoot down U.S.
spy planes
accusing them without evidence
of entering North Korean territory.
Warning in case of repeated
illegal intrusions, the U.S.
forces will experience
a very critical flight.
Past actions prove she's not all talk.
In 2020
a dispute with South Korea
ended with a bang.
Kim ordered the demolition
of a joint liaison office at the border,
turning diplomatic dreams
into a pile of rubble.